[Music]
welcome to Scotland and the bag pets
oddly remind me of Nova Scotia where I
grew up because Nova Scotia means New
Scotland in some other language than
English so what I wanna talk about is
something I get asked a lot about which
is how to learn to dance expressively
with poi and it's a good question and
the answer is it takes some practice and
a different kind of practice than what
you a lot of people usually do with poi
it's where people are usually doing is
they're thinking only about what the poi
are doing and they're going to play can
do this and the play can do this and the
play can do this and they can do this
and the poi can do this and that can be
awesome at least so it's a great point
moves but it doesn't tend to lend itself
to dance because you're only thinking
what the poi are doing if you want to
start moving more creatively and
expressively with your body you need to
start thinking about what your body's
doing but of course the problem is that
you got this play which might hit you as
you do that so the way I approach
learning to dance had a lot to do with
breaking down simple things through
ranges of motion so we can begin this
you can take your take any way you want
this pretty simple concept so we can
face this way together so we have a
plane you don't have to keep your plane
straight it's a choice I think it's a
good choice to be able to so we're going
to keep our planes this way now there's
three planes of motion that your arm can
go through one of them is with the poi
either in the same direction where you
do your in spins or the other direction
of the play which is anti spins and that
takes lots of time and lots of practice
in weeks/months
to get good at that there's also this
plane of motion
[Music]
and this plane of motion which is a lot
more neglected by post banners because
people won't see it as a POI move so
people will tend to only focus on these
planes of motion but that's what exactly
what leads to people being a bit static
with their bodies and you know the rest
of what's going on so I think it's a
great exercise to play with all those
ranges these ones lead to flowers which
is great
these ones won't lead to recognised poi
patterns but it will lead to a felt
sense of empowerment over total freedom
of body movement so I recommend there's
always lots of noise always when I try
to shoot tutorials or thoris but it's so
nice to shoot outdoors but there's
helicopters and bagpipes and dogs and
all kinds of so if you're newer at this
start with one play and really give that
time and there's gonna be one point
along the range where it might hit you
and you develop a sense of how to miss
and you got to felt a sense for that and
then on this one you just develop a
sense and then it only comes through
practice of not hitting yourself as you
get good at each arm eventually can go
to two arms and again we know we know
these ones leave the flowers and that's
all you know me and all the others lots
of other people in front of all these
videos about that what I see talked
about a lot less is these ranges of
motion
and these are though some people for
sure not dealing on playing with us by
any stretch there's other people
thinking about this now doing with
straight arms look stiff so it's just an
exercise the idea is by breaking it down
into something very simple you go places
you might not have otherwise gone in
fact you could even do playing this way
get to hear a plane this way get to here
a circle this way get to there as you
get good at that what you're going to
find is that you have a general freedom
to move more three dimensionally
although I'm in the grass on a hill so
I'm a bit limited and that will lead to
more intuitive freedom of dancing so
there's no it's not you know it's not
really moves it's thinking about how you
want to move and the way I approach it
as breaking it down into concepts like
that and practicing them but then when
the music gets good I let go of that I
just start to freestyle on how I'm
moving but because I practice practicing
that I find I have more freedom so
that's a noisy Scottish Hill nick
woolsey reporting from playboy how to
develop freedom of movement and
expression with play